is to find ways that you can promote and activate
those stem cells in your brain already
to react and respond appropriately to damage
to repair it.
That will be the future.
There will be drugs that will do that.
But the other way is to effectively parachute in cells,
transplant them in,
to replace dying or lost cells, even in the brain.
And I want to tell you now an experiment,
it's a clinical trial that we did,
which recently completed,
which is with colleagues in UCL,
David Miller in particular.
So this study was very simple.
We took patients with multiple sclerosis
and asked a simple question:
Would stem cells from the bone marrow
be protective of their nerves?
So what we did was we took this bone marrow,
grew up the stem cells in the lab,
and then injected them back into the vein.
I'm making this sound really simple.
It took five years off a lot of people, okay?
And it put gray hair on me
and caused all kinds of issues.
But conceptually, it's essentially simple.
So we've given them into the vein, right?
So in order to measure whether this was successful or not,
we measured the optic nerve
as our outcome measure.
And that's a good thing to measure in M.S.,
because patients with M.S. sadly suffer
with problems with vision --
loss of vision, unclear vision.
And so we measured the size of the optic nerve
using the scans with David Miller
three times -- 12 months, six months,
and before the infusion --
and you can see the gently declining red line.
And that's telling you that the optic nerve is shrinking,
which makes sense, because their nerves are dying.
We then gave the stem cell infusion
and repeated the measurement twice --
three months and six months --
and to our surprise, almost,
the line's gone up.
That suggests that the intervention
has been protective.
I don't think myself that what's happened
is that those stem cells have made new myelin
or new nerves.
What I think they've done is they've promoted
the endogenous stem cells, or precursor cells,
to do their job, wake up, lay down new myelin.
So this is a proof of concept.
I'm very excited about that.
So I just want to end with the theme I began on,
which was regeneration and hope.
So here I've asked John
what his hopes are for the future.
John: I would hope that
sometime in the future
through the research that you people are doing,
we can come up with a cure
so that people like me can lead a normal life.
SC: I mean, that speaks volumes.
But I'd like to close by first of all thanking John --
thanking John for allowing me to share
his insights and these clips with you all.
But I'd also like to add to John and to others
that my own view is, I'm hopeful for the future.
I do believe that the disruptive technologies
like stem cells that I've tried to explain to you
do offer very real hope.
And I do think that the day that we might be able
to repair the damaged brain
is sooner than we think.
Thank you.
(Applause)